>> Laura: AMERICANS CAN GET
THE CORONAVIRUS FROM JUST GOING
OUTSIDE.
AT THE LIBERAL MEDIA ARE NOW
TRYING JUST PARK PANIC OVER THE
PRESIDENT’S HEALTH.
>> WHY NOT GET TESTED YOURSELF
AFTER YOU INTERACT WITH THEM
LAST WEEK?
>> Laura: NO SYMPTOMS, THE
PRESIDENT HAS NONE.
WELL, THAT’S NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR
THE EXPERTS AT CNN.
>> WHEN I HEAR SOME OF THE
AMERICANS ONCE THESE TESTS,
THERE IS THIS TESTING, THAT’S A
BIG PROBLEM.
BUT WHEN THEY HEAR THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES SAYING I
DON’T THINK IT’S A BIG DEAL, IS
THAT THE RIGHT MESSAGE?
>> Laura: YOU MEAN THE MESSAGE
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS HEALTHY?
I THINK THAT’S WHAT THEY WANT TO
HEAR.
AND THAT’S WHAT EXPERTS ARE
TELLING HIM TO STAY.
>> SHE SAID THAT AT HER
HOSPITAL, EVEN IF YOU BEEN
POSSIBLY EXPOSED, AND EVEN IF
YOU JUST GOT OFF THE PLANE FROM
ITALY, IF YOU DON’T HAVE
SYMPTOMS, THEY DON’T WANT TO
TEST YOU.
EVEN IF YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN
EXPOSED, WHAT HE SAYING ACTUALLY
JIVES WITH WHAT DOCTORS ARE
TELLING ME.
>> Laura: THAT’S OWL THING
WHEN YOU’RE IN A COURT ROOM,
NEVER ASK A WITNESS A QUESTION
YOU DON’T KNOW THE ANSWER TO.
REMEMBER, TRUMP, THEY SAY IT’S A
REAL SCIENCE DENIER.
BUT CNN GAVE THIS NARRATIVE ONE
LAST SHOT.
>> YOUR THOUGHTS, SHOULD HE GET
TESTED?
>> I AGREE WITH THE PRESIDENT,
IF HE HAS NO SYMPTOMS, THERE’S
NO REASON TO TEST HIM, WITHOUT
SYMPTOMS, I DON’T THINK PEOPLE
NEED TO BE TESTED.
IF THEY SAY YOU’RE FINE, YOU
DON’T HAVE ANY SYMPTOMS, I AGREE
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE DOCTOR.
>> Laura: LET’S GO FOR A THIRD
TIME, JOINING ME NOW IS THE
DOCTOR YOU JUST HEARD
AFOREMENTIONED CARLOS DEL RIO,
PROFESSOR OF MEDICINE OF THE
GREAT EMORY UNIVERSITY.
FOX NEWS MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT.
DR. DEL RIO, WHAT ARE YOUR
MESSAGE TO ABEL WHERE PUSHING
THIS NARRATIVE THAT IT’S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF HIM NOT TO
RUSH OUT TO BE TESTED.
YOU’VE BEEN HEARING THIS IN THE
AMERICAN MEDIA.
>> WHETHER YOU HAPPEN TO BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OR NOT, IF YOU DON’T HAVE
SYMPTOMS, AND THERE IS NO
INDICATION FROM A MEDICAL
PHYSICIAN THAT YOU NEED TO BE
TESTED, YOU SHOULD NOT BE
TESTED.
WE KNOW THIS FROM LEVEL TESTS,
AND THIS IS NO DIFFERENT THAN
OTHER TEST.
IF YOU TEST PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
LOW LIKELIHOOD OF DISEASE, A
POSITIVE TEST WILL BE A FALSE
POSITIVE.
WE DON’T LIKE TO TEST PEOPLE
THAT HAVE A LOW LIKELIHOOD OF A
DISEASE.
IN THE CASE OF THE PRESIDENT, HE
HAD NOT A DIRECT EXPOSURE, AND
NO SYMPTOMS, NO REASON TO TEST
THEM.
>> Laura: AT DR. SIEGEL, WE’VE
SEEN THIS WITH THE CPAC ATTENDEE
WHO TESTED POSITIVE AFTER THE
CONFERENCE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS,
HE SHOOK HANDS, THEN THEY SHOOK
HANDS, THE HEAD OF THE CPAC CAME
ON THE SHOW, I SHOOK HIS HAND, I
HOPED HIS WIFE.
I GUESS BY THIS LOG CHECK, I
SHOULD BE TESTED FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS.
MY THROAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS, IT’S OF
LARYNGITIS.
>> YOU FORGOT I WAS IN NEBRASKA
MEETING WITH THE NURSES AND
DOCTORS WHO HAVE TAKEN CARE OF
PATIENTS, I DIDN’T GET TESTED.
>> Laura: AGAIN, IT’S A
MULTILEVEL, IRRESPONSIBILITY ON
THE PART OF ALL OF US, I GUESS.
BUT THIS JUST LEADS A LOT OF
PEOPLE TO GO INTO DEEP PANIC.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, WE HAVE
CORNERED THE MARKET ON PANIC, WE
NEED CALM AND PREPAREDNESS.
>> FOR SURE, WE HAVE CONCERN
ABOUT THE SPIRES, BUT WE KEEP
JUMPING TO THE WORST-CASE
SCENARIO SCENARIO, ENVISIONING
THE WORST, THAT’S WHAT
DESTABILIZING THE MARKET.
THAT’S WHAT’S GIVING EVERYONE
SEQUESTERED IN THEIR HOMES.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, THE
PRESIDENT SHOWED THE RIGHT
EXAMPLE, HE IS VERY SOBER GUY,
HE GIVE THEM THIS FIRST LESSON
HERE.
LISTEN TO YOUR DOCTOR, DOCTOR
SAID DON’T GET TESTED.
HE DIDN’T HAVE DIRECT CONTACT
WITH SOMEONE WITH CORONAVIRUS,
HE HAD CONTACT WITH SOMEONE WHO
SHOOK THE HAND AND HAD A
PHOTO OP WITH SOMEONE WHO HAD
CORONAVIRUS.
SO HOW MANY TIMES DO YOU LOSE
THIS GUY?
IF HE HAD GOTTEN TESTED, HE
WOULD’VE BEEN SENDING A MESSAGE
TO THE UNITED STATES, IF YOU’RE
WALKING DOWN THE STREET AND YOU
HEAR THAT SOMEONE IN THAT
HOSPITAL HAS CORONAVIRUS, WE
ADOPTED CIRCUIT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE CONVINCED THEY HAVE IT.
>> Laura: DR. DEL RIO, TONIGHT
IS A BIG ELECTION AND NIGHT FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
BIDEN SWEEPS TO VICTORY IN ALL
OF THESE PRIMARY RACES.
BOTH CANDIDATES HAVE CANCELED
THEIR BIG EVENTS, BIDEN IS
ADDRESSING ONLY HIS CLOSEST
SUPPORTERS IN PENNSYLVANIA
TONIGHT, BUT BERNIE SANDERS IS
NOT ONLY NOT SPEAKING TO
THOUSANDS AS HE HAD PLANNED TO
DO, HE’S NOT APPEARING IN
PUBLIC, APPARENTLY OUT OF
CONCERN FOR THE CORONAVIRUS.
DOES THIS MAKE SENSE IN ONE OF
THE HOT ZONES OR CONTAINMENT
ZONES, SUCH AS NEW ROCHELLE OR
MAY BE IN WASHINGTON STATE?
>> PART OF THE PROBLEM WE HAVE
IS UNFORTUNATELY, AS WE KNOW, WE
ARE WAY BEHIND TESTING IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AS WE RAMP UP TESTING IN THE
COUNTRY, WE ARE PROBABLY GOING
TO FIND A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INFECTED THAT WE DON’T KNOW
ABOUT.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, UNTIL WE
HAVE FURTHER DATA, WE NEED TO
ASSUME THAT THERE’S A LOT MORE
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE REGULAR
OF THAT HAVE TRANSMISSIONS OF
VIRUS.
ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES TO CONTROL THE
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS LIKE
THIS ONE IS WHAT WE CALL SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
IT IS PRUDENT TO HAVE A SOCIAL
DISTANCING, I THINK IT’S
APPROPRIATE THAT IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE TRY NOT TO BRING
A LOT OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
TOGETHER UP UNTIL WE HAVE BETTER
DATA.
ONCE WE HAVE BETTER DATA, I
THINK WE CAN MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, GO AHEAD.
>> WHILE I AGREE ABOUT HIS
PRINCIPLES HERE IN THE MEDICINE
OF THIS, I WOULD NOT COME TO THE
SAME CONCLUSION.
THE PARANOIA AGAIN, WE ARE GOING
TO ASSUME EVERY ARENA WE HAVE
HAS CORONAVIRUS IN IT?
IT’S JUST NOT -- WE DON’T HAVE
THE SENSE THAT THERE IS THAT
MUCH CORONAVIRUS HERE YET.
THERE’S DEFINITELY MORE THAN WE
KNOW ABOUT, HE’S RIGHT ABOUT
THAT, BUT WE DON’T NEED THIS
FEAR OF GOING OUTDOORS.
IT’S A GORE PHOBIA, THEY HAVE A
DIAGNOSIS FOR THAT.
GET
THE TESTING DONE.
I WENT TO A GAME LAST WEEK,
THERE IS NO ONE THERE.
OF THE NECKS OR TABLE, THAT
MIGHT BE THE REASON
>> Laura: THE NCAA MEN’S
BASKETBALL TOURNAMENT, WE ALL
HAVE OUR POOL -- WE ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE A POOL.
WE HAVE A FAKE POOL HERE AT FOX.
IF WE DON’T WANT ANYONE TO BE IN
DANGER.
THEY’VE ALREADY CANCELED THE
HALF MARATHON IN NEW YORK, THEIR
CANCELING CONFERENCES, IT IS
DOING HUGE HARM TO THE TRAVEL
AND ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY, AND
I THINK THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IS
SENDING PEOPLE INTO SOME PANIC,
SO THEY ARE GOING TO BUY WATER,
FIGHTING OVER TOILET PAPER,
THICK STOMACH THAT CAN BE GOOD
EITHER
>> IN FACT, I AGREE WITH YOU, I
DON’T THINK WE NEED TO SPREAD
PANIC, I WAS TALKING TO SOMEBODY
TODAY, I WAS SAYING THE BIGGEST
WRIST YOU HAVE MAY BE OF GOING
TO A BIG ARENA TODAY, OR GOING
TO A TOURNAMENT MAY BE DRINKING
TOO MUCH BEER AND FALLING AND
HITTING YOUR HEAD TO, AND FOR
THAT REASON WE ARE NOT CANCELING
THOSE TOURNAMENTS.
WE NEED BETTER INFORMATION, WE
NEED MORE DATA, AND WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THE DATA CAREFULLY, BUT
I COULDN’T AGREE WITH YOU IN THE
DOCTOR ANYMORE.
WE NEED PEOPLE TO BE PREPARED,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE DON’T
NEED TO SPREAD PANIC.
>> Laura: WE GOT THE TESTING
FINALLY SET.
IT MILLIONS OF TESTS WILL BE
PRODUCED IN THE COMING DAYS AND
WEEKS.